but you guys play just a little DVD
right
what DVD uh it can't for you in the mail
it says to my fresh dope son from MC mom
[Laughter]
we're playing that DVD come on em to the
C to the M or M and when it comes to mom
rappers I'm the biggity best of them to
my homie number one his name's Carl
Stewart but to me he's just your lesson
stuff behind that I can send you if you
need like your best friend there and
your magazines going through all this
stuff but it looks pretty risky we use
so much lotion but your socks sure are
crispy I've been cleaning with the broom
and the vacuum and found Victoria's
Secret is she's hiding in your room
every nook and cranny there are rods of
tissue I can't even open this swimsuit
issue I spilled a soda on that magazine
I'm getting your site so nice and clean
like when you wet your bed till you were
16 I overreacted sorry I spanked you
look another crispy sock
no thank you I'm going fine
crispy socks here crispy socks they're
crispy socks with some mystery hey we
got run it off right now come on you
guys come on started it we gonna finish
Oh oughta be changed up I got the
kitchen and the basement and the living
room and since he died met that [ __ ]
I got his office too got my juices going
but Rob's flowing my breath blowing
showing the signs are slowing I can feel
my skills growing took a little practice
to practice these lyrical gymnastics but
now the fact is queen bee I'ma be
somewhere not your [ __ ] mattress hell
yeah baddest [ __ ] in the biz sticking
the show on the road you can clean up
your own tears [ __ ] peace
[Music]
you